liberal cities seeing a surge in
violence this weekend while the left
continues to call for defunding the
police more than a hundred people were
shot in Chicago alone 14 were killed
including five kids an activist there
calling out the lack of outrage where's
the outrage where's the outrage for this
three-year-old that was killed the same
type of outrage when George Floyd was
killed by the police in Minneapolis
there should be 30 40 50 thousand people
on the streets right now shutting down
the black community until we get it
right we black men need to shut down the
black community until we get it right in
Minneapolis a shooting spree left one
dead and 11 people injured and in New
York City gun violence is up a
staggering 358 percent from this time
last year over in Seattle's cop free
zone protesters slowing down police
responding to a shooting but don't worry
it's all Trump's fault one of Seattle's
radical far-left councilmembers saying
that the president quote bears direct
responsibility for the violence in the
lawless cop free area all right Dan that
we've been talking about this for weeks
and weeks it's starting to happen
unfortunately I don't know if anybody's
gonna pet anybody on the back as people
are dying but this is the sad
consequence of what happens when the
defund the police movement takes hold
and cops pull back yeah it's not a great
time to be saying I told you so
but there are certainly people who are
raising the alarm now sometimes you see
violence have an uptick in the summer
this summer is probably increasingly so
because you have a economic situation
where there are a lot of jobs lost
you have no schools very few camps you
have people that are worried about their
health so their social distancing
involved on top of that you had the
George Floyd murder the protests
some of which turned into riots and
looting and now you see the fact that
the police in some cases are reports
that they have pulling back a little bit
or in a community like you saw at chop
Chazz whatever they're calling it now
blocking the police from actually
helping people and then being blamed for
that as well so yes it seems like a
lawlessness all across the board now
something is going to happen this week
and it's going to happen on Wednesday
there will be a vote on senator Tim
Scott bill to reform police on Wednesday
now it has 50 co-sponsors but the
democrats look like they are poised to
defeat this bill that they would not let
it go on for consideration now this is
biting off their nose despite their face
you have senator Tim skies been working
on this for years there's an opportunity
here to at least get it to the next
phase for discussion and I feel like the
Democrats are setting themselves up for
a big fail here because if you look like
you want the issue to campaign on rather
than you want the issue to be solved
people will hold you accountable for
that and it will be a real shame because
this is an opportunity where you have a
president willing to sign a bill
Congress in a bipartisan way hopefully
willing to do something and the big
concern just you know shut up after this
apparently the Democrats are upset that
the bill doesn't have a mandatory ban on
certain types of policing like chokehold
now what it does say is that there will
be incentives to make sure that local
police departments banned chokehold that
is similar to what happened when you had
the seatbelt laws or you changed the
drinking age from 18 to 21 you use
incentives from the federal government
and then almost always you have the
states fall in line we still do have a
republic and that is what this bill
would still allow but it would make sure
that police departments start actually
reforming so that they don't lose
funding from the federal government well
hopefully the Democrats don't play
politics to use this as a campaign issue
but it would not be the first time Katie
amazing what's happening in Chas or
chopped or whatever you call it we've
heard for days upon days from the media
that this
is a safe place this is just a bunch of
people having a block party and now at
the block party people are getting shot
and killed yeah people who are of
african-american descent black people
where Americans are being shot and
killed in these places where the police
have pulled back by the demands of the
City Council members and the mayors in
these liberal cities and I think it's
really important to point out while
police officers around the country are
being vilified and painted with this
broad brush and being accused of racism
and not being trusted well they're the
ones who are dealing with these types of
people for example in Chicago they're
the people who are who are dealing with
criminals who are willing to go around
in their own communities and kill
three-year-olds in the back of cars for
whatever reason that they see fit and
the people that are the victims of this
are the people who lose their lives and
the people in the community who want
more police who do not want criminals to
be running rampant as a result of a lack
of good policing and when it comes to
what Democrats have been pushing so far
I think every single one of them who
pushed for defunding the police in this
country need to be asked if they are
okay with what happened over the weekend
whether it's in Seattle or in Chicago
because if it were Republicans pushing
this every single one of them would be
asked by the media and by fellow
colleagues on Capitol Hill about the
consequences for this and be held
responsible for it and yet we haven't
seen those questions being asked one
katie brings up chicago deadly weekend
father's day horrible tragedy I follow a
guy's sunny mix sunny face he said
something brilliant which I have to give
him credit for he said this and you can
react to that he says the media is very
concerned about gun violence and the
media is also very concerned about black
victims of violence but they don't seem
to be so concerned with black victims of
gun violence how would you explain that
in Chicago I'm a little puzzled I think
that people are concerned about victims
of gun violence I think I'm just trying
to make sense of it in my mind but I
think part of it jesse is
what you're seeing is something Dana
hinted about which is that we have
all-time lows in terms of crime in the
country right now and we are especially
during the lockdown over the coronavirus
we saw crime even go lower and now it's
summertime and people a lot of people
are out of work a lot of people out of
school people are hitting the streets so
everybody who's been involved with
everything from drugs to partying to
just getting out of the house they're
out there now and I think you're going
to see as it's normal by the way when
summer comes a bump in terms of criminal
activity but in terms of stopping this
kind of spreading of fear I think it's
important to understand that
historically we are at a low point in
terms of crime in this country and that
we have to try to keep it that way so to
me you know it's a it's an important
distinction to be made because when
people call for police reform they're
not saying I'll let people go shoot each
other not at all I mean that's that to
me is a huge distortion of the argument
I think what you're really talking about
and I certainly hope you're not implying
implying the cops aren't doing their
jobs not upholding their oath I think
that what we're dealing with here not
employment is that you have people who
are not attacking strangers they're
attacking each other and in the case of
the Democrats they're not for defunding
the police they're for police reform and
so the poll show the American people are
for police reforms a week and avoid the
kind of brutality we saw with George
Floyd or the kind of abuse that many
black people are charged the police with
on a regular basis all right Dan I'll
let you respond to Juan's point yeah
it's interesting you know one does this
thing I find a no offense wants nothing
personal of course but I find a lot of
liberals do this as Thomas saw one said
they love to start the story in the
middle well it's like listen we're you
know we're at really low levels of crime
historically yeah one the first six
chapters of the book matter of how we
got there is because of aggressive
broken windows policing
I don't mean aggressive by the way
referring it anyway to the Horace show
on what happened to mr. Floyd there's
universal agreement that was just
grotesque to the highest order but
broken windows aggressive policing wand
is why we're where we are right now so
if you're suggesting that that's good
which I think most sane people would low
levels of crime are a good thing then I
assume you're on the five right now
supporting broken windows policing
which is aggressive policing you know
stopping people committing criminal
activity in the street checking them for
warrants so I applaud you for doing that
that's that's really strong that's a
bold move I don't see a lot of liberals
doing that way to go on so glad you can
come
Jesse Drive a set cup Jesse drivers real
quick sign there quick yeah sure yeah so
so I was then I just you know I am by
the way a fan of the 94 crime bill
because I think people today especially
in black lives matter weren't around in
the 90s when we had staggeringly high
crime rates but I'm not for harassing
people who have no criminal record if
I'm walking down the street there's no
reason to stop me and notice for them
and demand are bad I'm not even I just
think that's right that's not what
broken windows policing is one that's
the guy who jumps the turnstile they
stop them and they check them for
warrants they don't let it go that's
really like OD policing that's what got
us here all right all right well Dan got
Wanda great